このチャプターは無常と因縁という聖なる真理
無常は因縁やら仏教では聖なる真理
俗世間と関係ない 俗世間の人に発見できなかったという意味で聖なる真理というのです
で 真理っていうのは事実に基づくもの
生き方 仏教はこの真理
事実に基づいて生きなさいよと
観念 妄想 概念 気持ち 希望
こんなものはもう生きる衝動にしてはいけませんと
明らかに具体的にとうとうと事実に基づいて生きることなんです
お腹が空いても まあ神様は何か訳があって私をお腹が空くようにしたんでしょうと
だから我慢するぞということは意味がないんです
お腹が空いたらご飯食べればいいのです
それでもお腹が空いたんだけど
忍耐力が私にあるかないか試すためにご飯食べないんだよと思ったら
それも具体的な事実なんです
どうせ私は運が悪いんだからといって
ご馳走を誰かに用意してくれたっても
嫌で食べません なぜ？私は運命は初めから悪かったからと
そういう生き方はあまり賢しくはないんです
それを具体的に言って
で 今まで喋ったのは 私は無常と因縁の話なんですよ
なんかすっごい仏教と関係ないこと喋ってるような気がしたでしょ？でも喋ったのは無常と因縁の話なんです
イベントとは無常のことを
このイベント イベントと何か大胆なこと言ったんですけど
仏教用語で無常ということなんです
一切は物ではなく イベントだと見ることは
一切の現象は無常であるとありのままに知ることです
無常ということことです
お釈迦様の言葉で言えば
サンペーサンカラーアニッチャン
たったその一行ですよ
までずっと語ってきたのは
今にあるもの 今にいる自分
今にいる他人 すべては今という時間における出来事です
だからここっていうのはそんなにないんです
今 今にある自分 今にある他人
今にいる自分 今にいう他人
今にあるもの すべて なんでしたっけ？今という時間
時間で起きているイベント
出来事 成り行き ただ 私は元気だ
元気だと言って ずっとこの 4時間も立ちっぱなしで水も一滴も飲まないでいると
ずっと私は変わっていくんです
出来事ですよ 例えば 2時間
3時間経ったところで
別な自分なんです 疲れ果てていて
どこに声も出ない別なもの
それで水を飲んで休んじゃあ元に戻ったというのはとんでもない勘違い
元に戻りません 元気になった
元に戻ったと それ とんでもない話なんです
ありえないんです 別なイベントが起きただけ
私たちは元に戻ったと
元気に戻ります 戻れません
元気に 一旦元気になったら
それからまた要因因縁変えて
まあ別なものになるだけ
私はちょっと目が弱くなったところで
まあ調べて眼鏡をつけたんです
で 眼鏡をつけたら あの視力はだいたい 8 分ぐらいで見えたような感じで
2.0と言うんですか
まあよく綺麗に見えます
あ 元に戻ったじゃないんです
まあ悔しかったんですけど
あんまり明確にも見えないし
本も読みたくはないし
苦労するだから それで眼鏡かけたところで
まあ元前にあったようなレベルで見えるんだけど
目は決して元に戻ったわけじゃないんです
ずっと眼鏡は外せなくなっちゃっただけ
だから何か問題解決したんだからといって元に戻るではないんです
元に戻れないんです 先へ先へ
先へ先へなんです だからこのイベントなんです
無常ということはそういうことなんです
次の時間で変わるんです
なんでも 因縁は現象を作る
そこでイベントは誰？現象ですね
これは誰が作るのかというと
無常ではなくて因縁なんです
因縁も無常ですけど 因縁が現象を作るんです
今という現象は 様々な因と因で条件で一時的に成り立っているものなのです
様々な因縁 それ難しいことじゃないでしょうし
とっと成り立つだけ 今私がいると言ったっても
因縁で成り立っているだけ
だから因縁変わると私も変わってしまう
時間変わると私も変わる
時間止まりませんだから私の変わり方も止まりません
だからまあ 因縁ということも考えなくちゃいけないんです
また 文字が変わえたのは大事なポイント
覚えてほしいポイントなんです
因縁性がない現象は成り立たない
因縁で関係なく ない 何もない
どんなものであっても因縁で起こるんです
覚えてください この偶然ということはないんです
無から森羅万象を創造したということは明確な嘘です
あまりにも真っ赤な嘘です
成り立たないんです 事件から事件へなんです
皇太子は王になるんであって
一般人は王になれないんです
ですから 何もない 無から突然森羅万象がパーッと出たと
それ本当なら なんで今それ起きないんですかね？なんで神が自分を作った世界についてかなり悩んで
派手にいろんなことを聖書を次から次へと聖書を送ったり
それも一つ一つ互い違いものが何やってるのか
だからそんなのは全部根拠のない嘘になるんです
無常にならざるもの 因縁にならよらないもの
イベントにならないで固定して実体といったものはありえないということです
えーと まあちょっと文章はおかしいんですけど
とにかく直しています
因縁性がないとものは成り立たない
ですから 無常でないものはないんです
すべて無常です 因縁によらないものはないんです
一切は因縁によるんです
イベントにならないものはないんです
いわゆるこの固定は間違ってますね
あの 固定 固定変わらないものっていうのはないんです
固定したもの ちょっともう一つ肯定になっちゃったんですけど
固定した実体 いわゆるものはないんです
あるのはイベント そこはもう最終的に仏教の結論なんです
何でも何か原因であろうと
それで原因であろうが何であろうが
無常だからもう変わっちゃうんです
だから世の中すべてすーっと変わりつつのもの
流れなんです  え？因縁だから
無常だからこそ 何事も変えられるんです
だからまあ 何のことない
変えようと思っちゃえば変えられます
何でも だって条件変えればいいんだから
しかし  1日にして一発ってのはそんなのとんでもない話です
地球を破壊したければ破壊できますよ
今も世の中よく原子爆弾全部持ってきて
一口でついて爆破すれば地球は終わりです
それで 地球の殻も全部割ってしまうことさえできますよ
それで割っちゃえば それでかなり変わってしまうし
で わかりませんよ 変えようとすれば
でも 1日にしてはできませんから
ちゃんと順番で行かなきゃいけない
因縁を知ると道が定まるんです
この因縁であることをわかると
因縁を配慮すると できること
できないこと なれること
なれないこと 挑戦するべき
挑戦してはならないことなどが見えてきます
そこで 私というイベントが因縁で物事を考えると
何になれるかなとわかります
あれならなれます なりっこはないとか
例えば 今さら私は一流のピアニストになりたいと思ったら
よした方がいいんですね
因縁で考えれば これは 10年
20年ぐらいかかるし
今 60 年だから それ 23 年ぐらい
80 だから指が動くんじゃなくて震える時なんです
だからもうやめた方がいいと明確にわかるんです
だから この 因縁で考えると
何かになれる これならなれる
これならなれない これなら挑戦した方がいい
これならもうよしましょう
挑戦しないでよしましょうという
この道が拓けてくるんですよ
優柔不断がなくなるんです
訳の分からず人生を彷徨うことはなくなるんです
だから人類どうですかね
訳の分からず彷徨ってるだけでしょうに
何やってるのか本人がわからない
それは因縁と無常ということを知らないんだから
世界は物の世界ではなくて
イベントの世界であると知らないんだからそうなっているんです
時間の無駄と怠けがなくなるんです
これで時間の無駄と怠けがなくなるんです
時間を無駄にするということは本当はありえないことなんです
どんな時間でもやるべきことはできるんです
因果法則によって これはどうにもならない
やるべきことはやるしかないんです
だから そういう怠けの問題も消えてしまうんです
仏教の最高のキーワード
ブッダの最後のしつけの通りに生きることができるんです
因縁を知ったら 知ったならば
仏教で使うキーワードがあります
それは最高のキーワードがあるんです
それはお釈迦様の最後のしつけでもあります
最後の言葉 ワイダンマービッカウィサンカーラアッパマーデーナサンパーデーダ
比丘たちよ 物事は消え去りものです
イベントですということなんです
すべて怠ることなく励むのがよいと
怠れないんですよ 無常だから
無常を知らないんだから怠っているんです
だからお釈迦様は最後の最後に
息を止まるちょっと前にこれ言ったんです
すーっとこのアッパマーで不放逸ということをすーっと感じて語り続けたんです
だから一切イベントであると発見して悟りを出していたんです